bring in Chris Webber what sparkly mean
by this that LeBrons a drama queen and
therefore some players didn't vote for
him you know I'm not sure I think that
most players is really by Cathy Cooper I
think that they saw hard he played in
all-star game last year they saw that he
doesn't necessarily work out with the
players he's not in kind of the
buddy-buddy game groups that are in the
kind of NBA and I think that's
refreshing and I think the NBA players
feel that way so I think it's more about
like the respect for antic Hoople and
like seeing something do as opposed to
LeBron I mean everybody knows what
bronze you know the best player in the
game but maybe it's maybe it's fatigue
because I don't think that even us when
we do his gangs I don't you know I know
it seems like everybody just piles on
and it's a lovefest for the problem a
lot of times I don't think we really
respect or really put a lot enough on
what he's doing I think we just look at
a superficial or what a great pass but
we're so used to it but I really don't
know what Chuck means by that maybe you
know they took the tweet with Kevin Love
you know are you in or you out or or
maybe the fact we're behind us and say
much maybe those type of things I think
the players just really really respect
Mansur to kupo I know the Commissioner
said that he doesn't want to televise
this draft but how why can't we have the
the starting five telephone televise
Chris then I don't you know you don't
hurt somebody's feelings if they're you
know added to the roster or where
they're selected for the roster you know
you're the 15th guy but the starting
five for both teams would be fun
why can't we tell my dad yeah I agree I
agree I think that's something that's
coming I think they have to seal their
way through this and walk lightly
because they don't know it's kind of
what Peter sexist guys taking or the
embarrassment I think you do have to be
careful with that if guys are sensitive
in their you know 12 the special stone
on each side but I do think I think
we'll get to that five and then I think
we'll get to the whole team ultimately
because it's what the fans want is what
the players one of the players are fans
first so I agree with you cannot I do
agree with the NBA though I'm not gonna
lie that the first one or two let's see
how this works first before we
we started there's a god I understand it
but I'm like you I do want to see both
okay would you how would you feel if you
were the fifth guy selected in the
starting five when you were playing I
used to use anything and and I'm not
saying I'm special every player does
this in every sport but I used to use
anything to to stay feel with the
staying signifies and stay pissed off
and me personally it doesn't matter
let's say that a bloody was thinking
well better be take second or we don't
have problems on my team okay let's say
three well retreated and he's now I
better be on the eastern you know it
just seems like for me you know I would
definitely not be happy no matter where
I was picked unless it was first I would
use that as only stone after all-star
that level with the captain we wanna
come at their team you know some coaches
and I'm sure you know this uses coach
Angele or be nice you know the stories
of top is being nice to Kobe or Phil
Jackson being nice to one of the Tim
Duncan or some because guys remember
every little thing and and you got to be
careful somehow the guys are in the
coaches positions in are something funny
to watch talking to see web NBA on TNT
analyst I was surprised that the
Commissioner didn't come down harder on
the Houston Rockets who went you know
door-to-door with the Clippers there and
let me ask you about that you know the
punishment there and the fact that
Harden wasn't punished or Chris Paul and
you have this game coming up Saturday
night against Golden State just a
coincidence especially if they went into
the locker but we're talking about them
when did you go why were you going into
those whose locker room uh you know Gary
Payton is a very close friend but he's
like friends if you like that friend is
just this jerk man and so I don't know I
was hurt and I think it was the the
Olympic team within Baker and I was
cool event Baker but before the game
Gary just kept talking he's kept talking
and he was trying to pump me up and
basically I wanted I wanted my gold
medal and I thought that uh you know
then since you know you have this height
man darn king Payton over here talking
about how great you are
I need to show you if you weren't that
good in in fact give me that medal now
I'm gonna take it from just kind of just
it exploded and you ever do something
and you and after you like I don't know
what body I was in what what the hell
was I thinking kind of that type thing
Kevin McHale tells me one time he went
in the locker room after a referee and
they won the game hey but he did a
battery no intelligent super and he was
bad they called it a game and he was
telling me how third called I mean he
was just like yeah I can't lie to you I
know somebody has pretty much happened
before but but definitely something like
that where everybody knows and we kind
of know who was back there I definitely
thought that a couple of guys at least
one guy from Houston would be suspicious
but how close were you to getting after
Gary Payton after the game like do you
actually I didn't like it Oh Gary Payton
was pumped it up he was the hype man did
you get posted in Baker and we we called
each other you know but you know it
somebody broke it out after three
seconds so what was in a fight but you
know a couple you know weeks later we
went out and hung out so it was nothing
but that's yeah on the team that just
pumps pumps everybody up and makes it
the issue but I almost got in the locker
room yeah I definitely was sincerely
trying to have a one-on-one conversation
with him it's kind of a nice moment the
other night Chuck D of Public Enemy
tweeted that you were doing a great job
as an analyst did you see that yeah
before you know I'm a fan and a friend
of chucks and you know he was gonna talk
over Twitter but uh it's funny because
do you know that his Ryan style like his
voice told me that he used to listen to
Marv Albert growing up and that's how I
could he was such a Knicks fan and so
it's so funny that he really studies the
cadence
so you know I think well if I got no
other food I don't know how good I am
I know I've improved and I don't feel
the way that I used to or execute that
way and so it was cool that uh that he
took notice of it and being in he's a
were sniffing around man and we just do
as the coolest continent did you wrap
can you rap can I rap now I could make
beats for some of the greatest rappers
out that though and so Nash's album
surviving the times and did that for
most if blown ashes one as long as
greatest Church to others only hip hop
is dead I usually don't talk about it
but I'll produce for a Grammy nominated
artist and uh probably the greatest
rapper in my opinion if not top five
all-time so when it comes to music I'm
doubting heaven already so I don't I
don't mess around anymore uh I've seen a
mountaintop so to speak was not letting
me be on that album
let's see you don't create any more
beats you're done I do i do create these
but it's more for it's more for my
enjoyment and more for projects but I
love using my mom was like music
teachers I grew up like in the choir mom
I want us to be like a wine and she
takes six commissions I think she's a
fish so music has always been up in
Amazo it is cool to leave a mess for
people to love music wait wait your mom
wanted you to be the wining family yeah
like DC right yeah yeah but it started
like like with but the bigger brothers
it's like a wireless group there's five
brothers
I would lay upon Marvin wires so she
would make us you know stand up from
tallest to shortest and my father was
either looking at me cuz these tire he
just got in from work like if you do not
sing and just do what your mama does
imma kill you when we get home so you
know the pressure was ground but we
thought we were like yeah we're going up
it was fun I love that I'll leave you
with this Berkeley says that in maybe
Shaq agrees the Cavs won't make it to
the NBA Finals where do you stand
yeah you know like this the way they're
playing out they should not make it to
the NBA Finals but I don't know if I
trust another organization so let me
throw that monkey wrench in
and what do I mean I think teams are
going to be scared to pull the trigger
I think teams can be one player away
from going to the Eastern Conference
final and I think they're gonna be
scared to pull the trigger because of
the unknown I don't know if anybody
believes they can do it and they're
gonna put all they have into their team
and go for it
players will what about the can do the
cab's make that big deal today would you
bring in DeAndre Jordan give up that
number1 pick and say Tristan Thompson I
said last year that they should have
gotten cousins and I say it again if
they can get cousins of Jordan they need
to do it they don't have one shot
blocker yeah you know streets in town
say he's a great effort guy but in his
league there are no more dinners rather
there are no more beer policies it just
can't because of the way that the
Boston's moves and those guys were
incredibly great with dunking the finish
normal but you can play so far back off
of them even a guy like Tremont we know
how great he is but if you're playing
against them let him shoot 15 threes
it's better than him driving to the
basket getting a loop to JaVale drive to
the basket kicking it out to clay
Thompson driving the basket kicking it
out to the ranch so I think that you
know you need a guy that either can
dominate defensively because if you look
at it I don't think the Olympic team
wins without DeAndre Jordan period
period I don't care about how great
anyone else played other teams were not
respecting I was driving to the basket
they have big fellows that can play like
guards and so I think that if you were
leaving me to go get him or try to get a
guy like cousins but you know you have
to do it now all or nothing right now I
would think don't wait to see if LeBron
comes back or what happens I think you
have to put you have to go for always
good to talk to you Chris have a good
weekend and thanks for joining us thank
you guys appreciate that's Chris Weber
NBA on TNT analyst the players only
franchise I enjoy watching that Tuesday
night starting January 23rd got a
double-header cab Spurs Celtics Lakers
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you